can you count people for me what do you
mean so like who's the Hulk Hogan of
Comedy I don't know because I would want
to say Dane Cook but Dane Cook could go
like Dane Cook was like legit hilarious
who's Macho Man Bill Burr oh Bill Burr's
got like that intensity but it's like so
good in the ring Kurt angle's Nate
bargetzi he's an All-American [__] go
can like really go I'd say bargetti's
Kurt Angle I would say Shane Gillis is
Stone Cold Steve Austin wow smashing
beers and being like I don't give a damn
yeah it's gay the rock is probably is
that like Kevin Hart yeah yeah that's
great that's a good call and they're
like best and it makes sense they're
like yes buds that's a real good call it
is funny too good that the comedy analog
would be his opposite in like Dimensions
it really is it's like that but dude
that that you nailed it